こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
皆様は僕の、
お母様の存在をご存じでしょうか？
ＣＯＤＥ ＮＡＭＥ(コードネーム)
ＭＯＭＭＹ(マミー)
あのー
まあ、きっと優しさからくる
アンチだと思うんですけども
基本的に僕がやる動画にはいつも
文句を言ってきます。
そんなお母様が
今、僕の家に来ておりまして、
今日はなんと
特別ですよ。みなさん。
特別ですよ！
本当に、本当に特別です。
あの、基本的に僕の家の人は、
動画に出たくない！
動画に出たくないし、
もう、たぶん今日も嫌々だとは思うんですけども、
無事、お母様が動画に出てくれることに決まりました。
ありがとうございます。
ただ条件としては、
「顔を出すな」
「声も出すな」
「映すな」
「黙秘権を使わせろ」
と、4つの条件が出ておりますので
それを守ったうえで
今からTwitterでちょっと皆様に
僕のお母ちゃん、マミーに聞きたいことを
募集しますので
バンバンと、見つけたものから順番に
聞いていきたいと思います。
では行こう！
わかりました。一切撮りません。安心してください。
そこにお座りください。
ちゃんと、動画の最初で言っておきましたから。
「なんとか許可を得ました。」ってことを。
「はい」の時はこの〇を使ってください。
はい。
で、「いいえ」の時は・・・
黙秘権を構成する時はこちらを使ってください。
じゃあ、怒ったときはこれを使ってください。
じゃあ早速、Twitter民から募集してみましょう。
お母様：えっ、マジ！？
うん。
「マミーが来てるよ。」(パソコンに打つ)
お母様：えぇーーーーーー
えぇーーーーーー
今からTwitterで募集します。
「お母様に何か質問ある？」#はじめママに質問
よし、ＯＫです。
色々来たので早速聞いていきましょう。
「はじめしゃちょーは子供の頃どんな子？」
「ダメな子でした」ってこと？
どんな感じでしたか？
なるほどね。
比較的ね。
入院とか、してたね。
たぶん思っていた以上に弱かったですよ、子供の頃。
「子育てたいへんでしたか？」
ほう。
ほうほうほう
「お腹すいてますか？」
「はじめの直してほしいところ」
ん！？
部屋汚すぎ！
ちなみに、今の部屋はどうですか？
「なんでそんなに美人なんですか？」
あははーーー
あー、なるほど。
「家庭の育児方針的なものはありましたか？」
ほう。
ふーん。
確かに、大事なことです。
なかなか旬な話題が飛んでおりますが。
「はじめの吐く動画どう思いました？」
ぶーーー
「はじめんの武勇伝」
はじめしゃちょー＆お母様：あははーーー。
これは個人的に見ても気になるな。
「お気に入りの動画とかありますか？」
お母様：イギリスの時のマシュマロ！
マシュマロ？
お母様：どんどん投げて、パクパク食べるやつ。
お母様：イギリスの学食でマシュマロ選手権。
うわ、懐かしいなー。
あれ面白かった？
お母様：うん。あと、ポケモンを作るやつ。
ダンボールで？
お母様：ダンボールで。
あれ、したいけど時間が無くてなー。
お母様：まさきとの公園での戦い。
だんぼーるの？
お母様：ダンボールの。
結構お気に入りのもの言いましたね。
「息子がこんなにバカで困りませんか？」
あはははー
「はじめにYouTuber以外の職業何してほしい？」
お母様：あなたに向いている職業？
はい。
あはははー。
でも、昔パン屋になりたかった時期あったじゃん。
うん。
お母様：そんな人にパン屋さんはやってほしくない。
「ない」ということで。
お母様：はい。
はい。
これは俺らもね、記憶がないから逆に知りたいな。
「反抗期の思い出とかありますか？」
お母様：中学校2年生の時に
お母様：東京へ旅行したの覚えてる？
うんうん。
あははーーー。
あー、機嫌悪かったね確か。
あるじゃないですか、家族と居ることが嫌な時期。
お母様：「家族と一緒のグループにするな」みたいな。
家族といる時が恥ずかしい時期があって、
東京行ったときは常に、こういう顔していました。
あったね。すべてがイライラしてたもん。
「正直さっさと結婚してほしいですか？」
「はじめに一番腹が立っていること」
一貫しておりますね。
「YouTube始めたときどう思いましたか？」
最初言ってなかったよね、でも。
お母様：うん。
いつきずいたの？
お母様：言ったの。
俺が？
お母様：うん。
「YouTubeだよ」って？
どうでした？